THE INFORMATION IS COMING FAST
AND FURIOUS.
WE GO TO EVAN PEREZ WHO IS WITH
THE ATTORNEY FOR HUNTER BIDEN.
>> YES, CHRISTOPHER CLARK IS THE
ATTORNEY WHO IS DEALING WITH THE
CASE NOW FOR SEVERAL YEARS, AND
IT IS DESCRIBING THE OUTLINES OF
WHAT HAPPENING, AND THAT IS THE
AGREEMENT OF HUNTER BIDEN AND
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE OF
THE DISTRICT OF DELAWARE AND IT
IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
FIVE-YEAR INVESTIGATION INTO
HUNTER BIDEN IS RESOLVED, AND
THIS IS THE KEY SENTENCE.
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
FIVE-YEAR INVESTIGATION INTO
HUNTER IS RESOLVED AND HE IS
GOING TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
TWO MISDEMEANORS FOR FILING TAX
AGREEMENTS WHEN DUE, AND A PLEA
AGREEMENT, AND THE FIREARM
CHARGE IS DUE TO A DIVERSION
AGREEMENT, AND SUBJECT TO PLEA
AGREEMENT AND NOT FILED BY THE
GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS ALSO WHAT HE SAYS ABOUT
HUNTER.
HUNTER BELIEVES IT IS IMPORTANT
THE TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THESE MISTAKES HE MADE IN A
PERIOD OF TURMOIL AND ADDICTION
IN HIS LIFE, AND HE IS LOOKING
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
RECOVERY IN HIS LIFE, AND THE
KEY OPERATIVE PARTS OF THE
STATEMENT ARE THAT AT LEAST IN
THEIR DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
PROSECUTORS IN THE U.S.
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND AGAIN THIS
IS U.S. ATTORNEY DAVID WEISS BY
DONALD TRUMP APPOINTED TO
OVERSEE THIS INVESTIGATION, AND
THIS DEAL THAT RESOLVES THE
INVESTIGATION ACCORDING TO
HUNTER BIDEN'S ATTORNEYS
BELIEVES THIS RESOLVES
EVERYTHING, AND REALLY, THAT IS
AN IMPORTANT PART OF THIS PLEA
AGREEMENT, BECAUSE THIS
INVESTIGATION AS WE HAVE TALKED
ABOUT SPANNING FIVE YEARS AND
THREE ATTORNEYS GENERAL HAVE
LOOKED AT A LOT OF INFORMATION
INCLUDING HIS DEALINGS WITH
UKRAINE AND THINGS THAT
REPUBLICANS ARE NOT GOING TO LET
GO OF, AND THEY BELIEVE MORE
INVESTIGATION NEEDS TO BE DONE,
AND EVEN IF THEY BELIEVE THIS
INVESTIGATION IS DONE, CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION WITH THE
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN DELAWARE IS
OVER, AND MAYBE THEY FACE MORE
QUESTIONS FROM HOUSE REPUBLICANS
WHO ARE NOT QUITE DONE WITH THIS
YET.
KATE AND JOHN.
>> EVAN, STICK WITH US, AND
CONTINUE TO GET MORE SOURCES AND
STATEMENTS COMING IN WITH THE
STATEMENTS AND REACTION COMING
OVER FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
ARLETTE SEANEZ, WE ARE HEARING
FROM THE PRESIDENT AND FIRST
LADY NOW?
>> YES, THE FIRST REACTION CAME
IN MOMENTS AGO FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE AS THE BIDENS ARE
CONTINUING TO OFFER THEIR
SUPPORT TO THEIR SON HUNTER
BIDEN, AND WE WANT TO HEAR FROM
IAN SANDS SAYING THAT THE
PRESIDENT AND FIRST LADY LOVE
THEIR SON AS HE CONTINUES TO
REBUILD HIS LIFE.
HE ADDED THAT WE WILL HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS.
THE PRESIDENT IS OUT TRAVELING
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE EXPECT TO
SEE HIM IN THE 4:00 P.M. EASTERN
HOUR WHERE HE IS GOING TO HAVE A
SPEECH THERE, AND WE WILL SEE IF
HE HAS ANY MORE COMMENTS ON THIS
NEWS ABOUT HIS SON.
BUT THE NEWS FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE TRACKS WITH WHAT WE HAVE
REPEATEDLY BEEN HEARING FROM THE
BIDEN COUPLE RELATING TO THEIR
SON HUNTER.
THEY HAVE LONG STRESSED THEIR
SUPPORT FOR HIM, AND REALLY
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS SOUGHT TO
KEEP HIM CLOSE TO HIM HERE AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
HE IS A FREQUENT PRESENCE OVER
THE COURSE OF THE PAST FEW YEARS
AND FAMILY EVENTS AND COMING FOR
OFFICIAL EVENTS AND OUT MINGLING
WITH THE CROWD AS THEY HOSTED
THE ANNUAL EASTER EGG ROLL IN
APRIL AND HE TRAVELLED WITH THE
PRESIDENT OVER TO IRELAND AS
THEY WENT TO LOOK INTO THE
FAMILIAL ROOTS INTO THE
LONG-STANDING LOVE OF THE
PRESIDENT'S LOVE OF THE COUNTRY
OF IRELAND AS WELL, BUT IT IS
COMING AS THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
TRIED TO REFRAIN WEIGHING INTO
ANY MATTERS OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT INVESTIGATION INTO
HUNTER BIDEN AND THEY HAVE GONE
TO GREAT LENGTHS TO MAKE SURE IT
IS AN INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION,
BUT OFFICIALS HERE AT THE WHITE
HOUSE AND THE PRESIDENT'S
PERSONAL ATTORNEY BOB BOWER HAS
BEEN KEEPING TABS ON THE CASE,
AND BOB BOWER HAS BEEN SPEAKING
WITH THE LEGAL TEAM OF HUNTER
BIDEN TO GET UPDATES ON WHERE
THINGS STOOD, BUT THE BIDEN
FAMILY HAVE BEEN NAVIGATING THE
SITUATION FOR YEARS.
HE WAS A FREQUENT TARGET FOR
REPUBLICANS AND FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP BACK IN THE 2020
CAMPAIGN, AND BIDEN OFTEN AND
REPEATEDLY WOULD DEFEND HIS SON
HUNTER, INCLUDING HIS ADDICTION
ISSUES THAT HE HAD FACED, BUT
NOW TODAY AS THE FEDERAL CHARGES
ARE COMING TO LIGHT AS HUNTER
BIDEN IS PLEADING GUILTY TO TWO
OF THE FEDERAL CHARGES THE
PRESIDENT AND FIRST LADY ARE
MAINTAINING THE UNWAVERING
SUPPORT FOR THE SON IN THEIR
STATEMENT, AND WE WILL SEE IF
THERE IS ANY FURTHER REACTION
THROUGH THE COURSE OF THE DAY.
>> AGAIN, WE WILL SEE THE
PRESIDENT LATER TODAY, AND THEY
SAY THIS IS THE ONLY STATEMENT
THAT WE WILL HAVE TODAY, BUT I
WILL BE SURPRISED IF WE DON'T
HEAR DIRECTLY FROM THE PRESIDENT
TODAY.
BUT THE ATTORNEY FOR HUNTER
BIDEN SAYS THAT IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE FIVE-YEAR
INVESTIGATION INTO HUNTER IS
RESOLVED AND ONE PLACE THAT MAY
NOT SHARE THAT SENTIMENT IS
AMONG THE REPUBLICANS ON CAPITOL
HILL, AND WE WILL GO THERE.
OUR MANU VA
RAJA IS STANDIN
ANY REACTION?
>> WE HAVE NOT HEARD FROM
CHAIRMAN KEVIN McCARTHY OR ANY
OF THE KEY COMMITTEES
INVESTIGATING HUNTER BIDEN OR
ANY OF THE OTHER MEMBERS, BUT
THERE ARE SOME MEMBERS OF THE
RANK AND FILE QUICK TO CRITICIZE
THIS PLEA DEAL AND CRITICIZING
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SUCH AS
DARRELL ISSA CALLED IT A
COVER-UP, AND MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE WHO IS A CLOSE ALLY OF
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE KEVIN
McCARTHY SAID IT IS A QUOTE
STUNT, AND CALLED THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT PATHETIC, AND
CONGRESSMAN BOB GOOD, ANOTHER
MEMBER OF THE FREEDOM CAUCUS
CRITICIZING THIS AS WELL.
WHAT YOU CAN EXPECT FROM THE
HOUSE REPUBLICANS IN THE WEEKS
AHEAD IS TO ESSENTIALLY
INVESTIGATE THE INVESTIGATORS
AND FIGURE OUT WHY THIS U.S.
ATTORNEY DID NOT PURSUE, OR FILE
CHARGES OR IN WHAT HOW HE
HANDLED THOSE QUESTIONS ABOUT
HUNTER BIDEN'S OVERSEAS BUSINESS
DEALINGS THAT DID NOT LEAD TO
ANY FEDERAL CHARGES HERE.
THERE'S EXPECTED TO BE A LOT OF
CRITICISM AND THIS IS AN
ATTORNEY WHO IS A HOLDOVER FROM
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, AND
STILL NOT, AND THE REPUBLICANS
ARE INDICATING THAT THIS IS ALL
PART OF THEIR NARRATIVE THAT
DEMOCRATS SOMEHOW GET A PASS,
AND REPUBLICANS DO NOT.
WE WILL SEE IF THE FACTS BEAR IT
OUT.
THAT IS THE POLITICAL ARGUMENT
GOING FORWARD AND EXPECT THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE TO REPEAT
THOSE COMMENTS, AND NOW, EXPECT
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE, AND
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO SAY
THE SAME, AND THIS PLEA DEAL
REACHED AFTER AN EXHAUSTIVE
INVESTIGATION LEADING TO THIS
PLEA DEAL IS NOT GOING TO BE
MUCH FOR THE SATISFACTION HERE
ON CAPITOL HILL AMONG THE HOUSE
REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE MADE THIS A
CENTRAL INVESTIGATION LOOK INTO
HUNTER BIDEN AS WELL AS TO ANY
TIES TO THE PRESIDENT, AND THEY
EXPECT THAT TO BE THE FOCUS IN
THE WEEKS AHEAD, GUYS.
>> MANU RAJA, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
AND KEEP US POSTED AS TO WHAT
ELSE YOU SHOULD HEAR, AND WE
SHOULD NOTE THAT THIS IS A
TRUMP-APPOINTED U.S. ATTORNEY
WHO IS A HOLDOVER HERE WHO
STRUCK THIS PLEA DEAL.
>> SO YOU THAT.
AND OVER TO KARA SCANNELL
OUTSIDE OF THE COURT WHO HAS
BEEN TRACKING THIS WITH US.
AND KARA, YOU HAVE FRESH
REPORTING WITH THIS DEAL WILL
BRING WHAT PUNISHMENT?
>> YES, SO OUR UNDERSTANDING
ACCORDING TO THE SOURCES IS THAT
THE U.S. ATTORNEY'S OFFICE HERE
HAS AGREED AS PART OF THE PLEA
AGREEMENT TO RECOMMEND TO THE
JUDGE THAT HUNTER BIDEN SERVE NO
PRISON TIME AND HE BE PUT ON
PROBATION FOR A SET PERIOD OF
TIME AND THAT IS ABOUT 24
MONTHS.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN THE DETAILS
YET, BUT THE COURT FINDINGS
INDICATE THAT THE DETAILS
INCLUDING THIS PLEA AGREEMENT
DEAL BE PLACED BEFORE THE COURT
WHEN IT IS SET, AND WE HAVE
LEARNED THAT HE IS NOT GOING TO
BE FACING ANY JAIL TIME OR
PRISON TIME AS A RESULT OF
PLEADING GUILTY TO THE TWO
TAX-RELATED MISDEMEANORS AND IT
IS DRAWING A REACTION FROM
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO IS
POSTING THAT THIS IS A DEAL THAT
EQUATES TO A MERE TRAFFIC
TICKET, AND THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT MAN
MA
THE HILL.
AND SO, WE WILL BE HEARING OF
WHEN THAT IS GOING T
E
WHAT WENT WRONG WITH THAT AND
SO, WE WILL SEE IF THAT IS
DROPPED IF HE MEETS A CERTAIN
PERIOD OF TIME WITH THAT DEAL.
>> SO PROBATION.
OKAY.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS
IN TERMS OF THE THIS DEAL AND
WHERE IT SITS.
JOINING US IS OUR LEGAL ANALYST
ELIE HONIG, AND PAULA REID IS
SOMEWHERE WITH US.
AND ELIE, LET ME MAKE ONE THING
CLEAR, THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
BEEN SAYING THAT HE DID NOT
THINK THAT HUNTER BIDEN DID
ANYTHING WRONG, BUT THIS IS AN
ADMISSION THAT HE DID SOMETHING
WRONG.
>> YES.
>> HUNTER BIDEN IS SAYING THAT
HE BROKE THE LAW, AND HE IS
AGREEING TO PROBATION, AND TALK
TO ME ABOUT THAT.
>> PROBATION MEANS NO PRISON AS
LONG AS YOU COMPLY WITH ALL OF
THE CONDITIONS, AND THERE IS
GOING TO BE A SPECIFIC SET OF
CONDITIONS ON THE PROBATION, AND
VARIES CASE TO CASE, AND FIRST
OF ALL, NO FURTHER CRIMES WHILE
YOU ARE ON PROBATION, AND
TYPICALLY IN A CASE LIKE THIS, A
CONDITION LIKE THIS IS DRUG
TREATMENT AND REGULAR DRUG
TESTING AND WEEKLY, MONTHLY,
DAILY, AND YOU HAVE TO REPORT
INTO THE PROBATION OFFICER WEEK,
DAY, VAR RIS BASED ON THE
INDIVIDUAL.
I THINK THAT THERE IS ANOTHER
IMPORTANT PART OF TIME AND THE
POLITICS ABOUT THIS.
I HAVE SAID IT BEFORE THAT THE
FACT THAT IT TOOK FIVE YEARS IS
OUTRAGEOUS, AND INEXPLICABLE
DATING BACK TO 2018.
THINKING OF THE NATURE OF THE
CHANNELS FOR TWO FULL YEARS,
2018 THROUGH THE THE END OF 2020
THIS IS HANDLED BY DONALD TR